ce restaurant n'aurait pas été mon
premier choix par contre je suis fan de
ces petits biscuits chinois de la chance
vous savez j'ai pensé que ce serait une
bonne idée de discuter de tout ça entre
adultes
qu'est ce que tu veux la seule chose que
j'ai toujours voulu amener la lumière
dans les ténèbres apporter la vie là
willy à la mort
vous êtes mal placés pour parler de la
vie avec tous ces gens vous avez tué lui
jessica jaune le demandeur kitchen
la grogne fils je pense pas que vous
avez formé d'une sorte de croo
je vous assure que c'est très temporaire
il vaut décevront tous et si je peux me
permettre de vous donner un conseil
plus vous aurez de connexion avec eux
plus il sera facile de vous brisez
je me conseille guy ritchie
new york est une ville extrêmement
peuplée
il ya constant plus qu'on sortira tissu
oui
ce n'est qu'une vie tu t'habitues haha
les voir s'effondrer
mais tu les allume
allais-je maire de sciez ces points ne
tue c'est elle